let's jump to the story from billboard
Travis Tritt Cuts all Anheuser-Busch
products from his tour writer following
Brands trans-inclusive campaign
so it's not just Travis Tritt I believe
John Rich Kid Rock obviously and
apparently many others uh Travis Tritt
is saying there's many other artists who
are just totally getting rid of
Anheuser-Busch we're also hearing that
tons of liquor stores bars are getting
rid of Anheuser-Busch products we heard
that in Saint I think it was in St Louis
uh no no it wasn't it was in Missouri
somewhere they shut down a Budweiser
Clydesdale event because of the backlash
they've been receiving over the
sponsorship of Dylan Mulvaney so what is
the sponsorship now I think this is
something you can educate people on so
is he sponsored in the sense he given
cash or given does he get cash for
estimates selling it on on estimates are
fifty thousand dollars for Dylan
Mulvaney to do a video drinking
Budweiser so he gets does he get video
does he get cash from people viewing it
Budweiser called them called Dylan
mulvanian said we will give you fifty
thousand dollars to make a video oh so
he got money just to do what he did
because he's an influencer they're
paying 10 million 11 million followers
yeah they're paying for time on his
social media so he's not getting a
commission he just got the money just
the money so uh I want I want to stress
this too as I have to do I do not
believe that Dylan Mulvaney is a
transgender individual I believe that
Dylan Mulvaney if you look at I talked
about this earlier actually uh Dylan
Mulvaney is phase two of what is known
as Elsa gate it is the next level of
what Elsa gate is uh are you familiar
with Elsa gate no so when YouTube
enacted its algorithm or to a certain
degree the algorithm got to a point
where
people were using computer programs to
Auto generate videos that would fall in
line with the algorithm to maximize
viewership so they'd make money what
ended up happening was there was a wave
of videos God Bless America well it
wasn't America if you know what I mean
it was uh it was like it was it was
mainly India I believe the market works
there were videos emerging where Elsa
was eating feces out of the toilet
getting injected with blood syringes and
giving birth then there was the Lesser
videos where it's like the Joker
Spider-Man and Elsa were running through
houses and doing weird things but many
of the videos depicted strange little
cartoon people eating and drinking out
of toilets being injected and having
other grotesque things done to them
bleeding from their mouth teeth being
ripped out and it was because these
things triggered the triggered the
algorithm so when parents would give
their iPad to a baby
and Press Play in a nursery rhyme and
then leave they hear some woman being
like hello little baby let's sing a song
and they're like that sounds wholesome
they leave the room
the video ends five minutes later
YouTube then Auto plays whatever fits
the algorithm after about five videos
you are in the insane world of Elsa
eating feces this this is Elsa gate this
is what happened yeah so what happens
with Dylan Mulvaney is that Tick Tock
makes an algorithm Dylan Mulvaney was
making a series of content like animals
nature didn't work
did it coming out as as a non-binary got
a few hundred thousand views did a
full-on day one of being a girl got
millions of views Dylan Mulvaney then
says ding light bulb this is what works
Dylan Mulvaney then decides to pursue
this course of content and then slowly
begin the process of doing drugs and
whatever to fit that mold to make money
hence Dylan Mulvaney prancing around in
the woods wearing high heels is not
something a trans individual does or a
woman does it is a caricature and it is
a real-life version of Elsa gate the
algorithm mashed these things together
and Dylan mulvani said if I do this I'll
get clicks so to any sane adult seeing
an adult human male taking hormones and
getting surgery putting on high heels
and running through the woods you'd be
like okay hold on this is really really
weird but all of these different things
combined make the algorithm promote it
so this individual gets views and then
pursues doing more of it this is what
Bud Light sponsored so for most of us we
are saying rational adults we see Elsa
eating feces and we go something's wrong
this is this is not right kids should
not be watching this we then see Dylan
Mulvaney and say okay this is not what
women do this is really weird what is
this
but young people don't know the
difference so when babies were being fed
elseigate they just watched it when
young pre-teens and teenagers on Tick
Tock see Dylan Mulvaney they just watch
it but where where are the adults and
Budweisers say that I'm assuming the way
it works is they've got their marketers
right who are in the thrall of whatever
you know fattest social media
especially to the the more to the left
the more politically correct the better
but isn't there an adult who says no no
we don't do this the adults are
millennials you know you can't do this
the Millennials I I think this is the
most fear-based decision-making where
where there my view is the leadership of
Anheuser-Busch needs to be held
accountable for allowing this to happen
because I think they know better
and they're afraid of
I don't agree the thugs in their own
offices I think it would impose this
thinking on them I think it's going to
get worse and I think it's much much
much more simple than that the 35 year
old woman who got promoted two years ago
to a marketing manager for Bud Light is
running the room right now and saying
this Dylan Mulvaney has 11 million
followers let's do this campaign that's
all that happened the people at the top
the executives at budweis are probably
older gen xers and some Boomers probably
have no idea what the campaign was but
they certainly learned about it now and
now they're saying what is going on and
it's going to get worse Millennials were
raised on these algorithms it was 10
years ago it was 15 years ago we're
talking about 2006 2007 the emergence of
social media algorithms
people who are getting out of college
create an existence on Facebook where
they're fed nothing but this
intersectional feminist garbage because
the algorithms were sending that kind of
content if the only thing you see for 10
years is that the United States is white
supremacist then you are going to live
in a world where that's true you've seen
nothing but evidence proving it now
you're 30 years old you're working as a
you know you're working at a low entry
level position at Budweiser
Anheuser-Busch now you're 35. you've
been given a promotion you are now head
of marketing for your division
it's that simple and then this person is
in charge and they fill it out now it's
possible the rumor is that at
Anheuser-Busch they're reeling from this
and the executives are furious at this
person someone posted the LinkedIn for
the woman who runs marketing I guess and
it's like a 35 year old Millennial woman
I think what's going to happen is there
may be a reprimand here if enough people
boycott Anheuser-Busch products to the
point where they're forced to issue an
apology they have if they don't answer
an apology they'll wait for it all to
blow over but if conservatives and
anti-wok individuals hold that for a
long enough period of time and say we
will not buy any of these products and
then the end of next quarter comes and
their stock drops because of it their
share prices then they issue an apology
and that creates cultural ripples
however
it is going to be a genzir who replaces
as Millennial woman and that gen zir is
going to have more hyper radical views
it is not in my opinion that some guy at
Bush at Anheuser Bush was like you know
we should go after young people and hire
Dylan Mulvaney it was a young person
hired who said this is what's popular
let's do it do you remember a couple
years ago I mean probably a long time
ago at this point there was that Kendall
Jenner Pepsi ad that got a lot of
backlash where there's like a protest
and magically Kendall Jenner gender Saul
she saves the day she saves the day I
don't know what her name is no gender
um but they she like passes over a Pepsi
can and everything is good and that was
widely balanced as being you know so
ridiculous so brave just mocking sort of
social justice efforts whatever
I worked at a PR firm at that time and
we had a whole discussion as a company
on it being like what did we learned
from this that this was a terrible idea
great how could we have stopped this
literally talking to anyone else in the
room but it's you know they'll have
these marketing teams that are like I
think this could be cool and we can get
Kendall Jenner and they're like oh my
gosh great idea and none of them can see
past it so what they know is that is
trending and they're like well might as
well jump on this bandwagon they can't
see the consequences I disagree it is a
millennial woman who likes Dylan Mulvane
that's what I'm saying it's all the
millennial women in the same room being
like still moving he's cool right so
it'll work it'll be fine and they're not
thinking about the consequences
themselves if we got dull mulvani to
drink Bud Light for March Madness that
is brilliant oh my God and now you've
got some 58 year old dude in in the
upstairs being like what am I what is
Kid Rock doing he's shooting our product
why is he doing that and they'll be like
well because you've got this histrionic
sociopath yeah drinking your beer and
now people are it's off was buying Bud
Light
what about the Nike ad oh yeah but let
me let me let me let me put this simple
for everybody to understand
there are a lot of people on the left
who are alike but it's so great that
Dylan Mulvaney is having fun and
drinking beer okay how would you feel if
Bud Light did a sponsorship of Infowars
and Alex Jones came out with a pack of
Bud Light and said Bud Light sponsor in
the show thanks Anheuser-Busch you're
the best and then and then he stabs it
shotguns it Slams on the ground raw rips
his shirt off we'd probably laugh right
but the left would lose their minds
sponsoring someone who is culturally
divisive is probably a very bad idea
which is funny because companies tend to
avoid those sponsorships it's cancel
culture they're like f we work with this
company you know we're going to get in
trouble
so going for Dylan Mulvaney was like
what did Stephen Colbert call it
sticking your dick into a hornet's nest
that's what he called it 10 years ago
with HB Gary I'll use the same analogy
that's what they did yeah and I think
because they don't have anyone their act
who's actually buying their product in
their marketing rooms when they're
having this conversation no one is like
that's a bad idea they're all talking to
each other they all watch the same kinds
of content online and so therefore
they're all attracted to the same
influencers and in this case it's
um uh radical divisive figure but
there's no one in there who probably
drinks Bud Light regularly who is like
this won't sell to anyone please stop
immediately there's no check in balance
system in the marketing agency yeah and
if it were only interested in
advertising controversy it'd be one
thing but you know you had the Supreme
Court cave in to the transgender
extremists by refusing to protect women
and girls in West Virginia from having
to compete against boys that's temporary
though I mean that officially hasn't
gone through its ruling this is just
saying that that rule can be enforced
right now no that the rule can't be
enforced right now the world can't be
foreign
Patrick Morrissey argue in front of the
case yet but you know typically the
courts intervene when there's a
likelihood of danger and this is
dangerous the the celebrate Easter
evidently uh the bite Administration
just issued a rule demanding all federal
funded programs sporting programs uh uh
refused to protect little girls by
requiring males to be allowed to
participate so this is a fanaticism and
as I keep on saying it's it's a
dangerous extremism
because it relies on this implication of
Violence by your opponents and it's the
and and it and it
focuses on
grooming children I want to jump to this
other story you were mentioning a moment
ago that the left isn't they don't
actually care about uh racism or I
forgot exactly how you phrased it but
basically the view is the the woke left
they're actually very racist thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time